Politicians and bureaucrats spend a lot
of their time making new laws and regulations
to protect the public. But now that sh*t has really hit the fan. Even the government is realizing how
many of those are unnecessary. Here are 10 measures created in the name of public safety
that have been set aside in the name of public safety.
The CDC testing monopolies perhaps the biggest and most obvious clusterf*ck on the list,
the agency mandated that only it could create and distribute tests and when they finally did roll them out,
they turned out to be painfully slow and
wildly inaccurate. Only after this colossal failure
did they allow private companies into the game, which has led to more testing kits that deliver faster results.
If only that had happened months ago. HHS is issuing a regulation today
that will allow all doctors and medical professionals to practice across state lines.
That is fantastic news except for the fact that HHS doesn't have that kind of authority.
Each state has jurisdiction over who can practice there. Not surprisingly HHS has been pretty quiet
about the issue. But at least some states have waived restrictions making it easier for doctors to be doctors.
You know things are serious when the TSA is easing stupid restrictions.
Since 2006 the agency said that having more than 3.4 ounces of liquid in a container was super
dangerous on airplanes. But now that actual danger is around and no one is flying,
hand sanitizer in 12 ounce bottles is a-okay. Speaking of hand sanitizer here's some good news from the Alcohol
and Tobacco Tax and Trade Bureau, also known as the TTB because I don't know. Distilleries around the country
can now make hand sanitizer without jumping through a metric f*ckton of red tape
including permits, bonds, authorization, formula approval, and taxes.
These waivers are only approved through June 30th however, after which that same hand sanitizer might
once again be very dangerous. Anyone who makes or sells alcohol is well-versed in ridiculous
and counterproductive regulation. But with the crushing blow social distancing
brings two restaurants at least one
strip of red tape is being snipped.
State and local governments are lifting bans on alcohol home delivery which is
welcome news to bars, restaurants, and
anyone stuck at home paying attention to
the news. The FDA has been easing a bunch of restrictions including relaxing rules
on ventilator manufacturing, allowing
pharmacists to make hand sanitizer,
declaring previously unapproved
respirators as totally safe now,
allowing outside groups to make diagnostic tests, easing access to antiviral drugs,
allowing the use of medical devices that remotely measure vital signs,
and allowing veterinarians to utilize telemedicine,
which was previously prohibited because I don't know. Medicare is now paying for telemedicine visits
which makes a lot of sense for people
who can't leave their house easily,
or are at greater risk of infection, which come to think of it as basically everyone who is on Medicare
to begin with. HHS said that even though they don't fully conform to HIPAA rules regarding privacy
and security, doctors may now use Skype and FaceTime for telemedicine,
because the future is now! Or at least it was 17 years ago.
Numerous states are freeing nonviolent offenders who were put behind bars
for technical violations or because
they simply couldn't afford bail.
Cite and release policies are also being
enacted across the country,
keeping low-level offenders out of jail if there is no risk to the community and it's a
pretty damning admission by authorities
that for a long time they've been just
fine with locking people up who posed no
risk to the community.
And plastic bags are back baby. After a hot and heavy fling with reusable grocery bags
politicians are waking up to realize
that canvas totes have a secondary
function as microbial party buses. So
what once was banned is now required
and vice versa. But in the name of public
safety, subject to change.